e
[Musique]
nos étudiants les chauves-souris de ces
grottes parce que les chauves souris
sont suspectés être des réservoirs un de
plusieurs agents pathogènes incluant
d'or le virus ebola
donc en dehors de la surveillance et les
virus responsable des amériques virale
nous surveillons également d'autres
virus dans ces populations animales
[Musique]
non
on le sait il ya des maladies qui passe
de l'homme à l'animal de l'animal à
l'homme c'est ce qu'on appelle les
zoonoses
donc il faut arrêter de penser que
l'homme et de son côté que l'animal est
de son côté
aujourd'hui on sait que ce qui va se
passer en santé humaine
ça va affecter la santé animale et vice
versa aujourd'hui on dit que des
épidémies peu augmenté à cause des
pratiques aussi humaine 1 qui de plus en
plus les exposent à ces animaux-là 10
réservoirs où ces animaux porteurs de
virus les pratiques de chasse
l'exploitation forestière
[Musique]
et
chasseur est très important pour moi
parce que quand je sais un peu de voir
je souhaitais qu'ils viennent ici
en fait le smig abonnés pas respecté on
est à moins de ça me fend le salaire et
quand je suis dans ma partie de chasse
ça arrive que annuler ni j'ai gagné
parce que c'est que j'ai gagné deux mois
[Musique]
laissez les gens ne sont pas inquiets du
virus parce que à ce nouveau site est
bête et ne sommes pas informés
[Musique]